after days of wrangling finally an end
to all the speculation the 28 EU member
countries agree on their nominees for
the bloc's top jobs first and foremost
we have chosen two women and two men for
the four key positions a perfect
gentleman I am really happy about it
after all Europe is a woman I think it
was worth waiting for such an outcome
the nominee for you Commission President
Germany's defense minister a seraph on
the line the conservative former family
Minister is the first woman to be
nominated for the EU stop job right up
until the last minute German Chancellor
Angela Merkel said she'd supported the
previous nominees but she's satisfied
with today's outcome in yeah it's a good
sign that mrs. fun de Lyonne enjoys
strong support among the heads of state
and government for different reasons you
start some three young Chefs oskins
whether it's for NATO's mission in the
Aegean on migration or Germany's
assistance with air surveillance in the
Baltics invited to come light like lace
or simply for her hard work for Europe I
not came as fast as he can fart in my
fuel buying is it stud as pick for the
new head of the European Central Bank
the leaders were unanimous in their
backing for Christine Lagarde currently
head of the International Monetary Fund
Lagarde is seen as a safe pair of hands
Belgium's former liberal Prime Minister
Charles Michel would succeed Donald Tusk
as president of the European Council
Spanish Social Democrat Josef morals
would take over as Europe's foreign
affairs chief but the biggest hurdle in
this political race has still to be
cleared the European Parliament has to
approve the lineup and the Social
Democrats have already set themselves
against it well for some analysis now
let's go over to DWS max Hoffman he's in
Strasbourg where the European Parliament
is meeting today
max the ball is now in the EU
Parliament's court
what do Emme peas their make of the
nominees that they've been given by the
European Council for the top jobs let's
go back a couple of weeks remember most
of the European Parliament said they
would only support a candidate for the
Commission presidency who previously was
a so-called Spitz Encana dog which is a
lead candidate for one of the political
groups right here in Strasbourg Boozer
laFonda Lyon is not that person and you
can imagine that among the political
groups here there is well I wouldn't
call it happiness because of that
decision now you have the Conservatives
was it up on the line is a conservative
she's a member of the European People's
Party so they'll probably come around
the real problem here lies with the
Social Democrats they are not at all
happy with this decision first of all
it's not as pits in county dot second of
all they were very close themselves to
have the Commission presidency with
constant months and we're hearing that
there is huge trouble in that group how
to go forward now the EU Parliament is
voting on its own president this morning
max how was that going there are four
candidates that have declared their a
part of that race as of yesterday 10
o'clock in the evening that was the
deadline but we do expect one of the
Social Democrats to make that race there
is one from Italy David
Sasol DS sort of a surprise candidate a
former journalist and
it's neither the conservatives nor the
liberals have declared any candidacy we
assume that this is part of that broader
deal that was that was struck in in
Brussels so we do expect david says
solely the social democrat from italy to
get the voices also from the
Conservatives and the Liberals and that
would be enough of course together with
the voice with the votes of the Social
Democrats to put him over the edge it
might take one or two rounds but it
should be a done deal and this is why
it's difficult for the Social Democrats
because if they do this they sort of in
a way are part of that backroom deal
that was struck in Brussels because the
leaders in Brussels said that the Social
Democrats should have the position of
parliament president and in this case
it's going to be hard for them to get
out of this whole package deal when they
vote on the Commission presidency so
effectively use what I've underlined in
two weeks time so still a bit to be
sorted out there max Hoffman for us
there in Strasbourg thank you so much
let's take a closer look now at ursula
von der Leyen
if confirmed as European Commission
president the 60 year old would become
one of the most powerful politicians in
the EU but as we have already seen her
nomination is not without controversy
and in her current role as Germany's
defense minister she's also faced many
challenges she's considered a close ally
of German Chancellor Angela Merkel
Ursula Fonda line German defence
minister Christian conservative and
longtime politician a medical doctor and
mother of seven fund aline joined
Merkel's CDU party in the early 90s she
later headed the Ministry of family and
women before serving as minister of
labour as Germany's first female defense
minister fond a line aimed to revamp the
Armed Forces but she's recently drawn
criticism for poor management in the
ranks several scandals including
revelations of far-right extremists in
the military equipment failures
deadly military plane crashes have
plagued her tenure a European at heart
fluent in both English and French as
well as German Thunder line has long
been seen as a possible successor to
Merkel as Chancellor or more recently as
the next head of NATO European leaders
have now agreed to choose her as the
next president of the EU Commission if
the European Parliament endorses her she
would be the first woman to fill the
influential post our political
correspondent hunts blunt is covering
this story for us and joins us now from
our parliamentary studios Hans Germany's
Defence Minister Ursula von der Leyen
has been nominated to head the EU
Commission what's the reaction here in
Berlin well when the name was first
floated on Tuesday sometime during the
morning everyone was very surprised by
this this was on not a name that anybody
had expected would come up for a head of
the Commission there had been some talk
about Olaf underlined possibly becoming
one of the commissioners in other words
becoming something like a minister in
the European Parliament but that she
would become Prime Minister that
government effectively that is something
nobody expected so surprised with the
first reaction then there is also some
sense of satisfaction I think one can
say am i especially amongst
conservatives in Berlin in Germany
because she is a conservative politician
because this means that a German world
for the first time in decades in more
than 50 years head the European
Commission
so in some sense also there is a feeling
that Angela Merkel as German Chancellor
put forward a candidate or supported in
the end a candidate that also increased
Germany's role in European politics so
you say Chancellor Merkel supported this
nomination but formally Germany actually
abstained from voting on Ursula pond
Alliance nomination for Commission
President why yes we've just heard from
Max and Strasbourg how controversial
this nomination is amongst Social
Democrats and we have to remember that
in Germany Angela Merkel is governing
together in a coalition with the Social
Democrats and the Social Democrats here
in Germany
have been vehemently opposed to the
nomination of oz' laFonda lion so
Germany has abstained formally because
Angela Merkel did not want to endanger
the atmosphere endanger the coalition in
Germany here so it's basically out of
respect for the Social Democrats at the
same time we have to say that there is a
little bit of a cloud hanging over Earth
laFonda Lions head in the sense that in
her defense ministry there's an inquiry
a parliamentary inquiry going on about
about spending in that ministry and it's
not clear whether the laFonda lion will
survive as it were politically survive
this inquiry
now hence if the European Parliament
does approve us laFonda Lions nomination
to head the European Commission what
would this mean for Germany well Germany
will certainly feel proud because as I
said it's been 50 more than 50 years
that there has been such a top German
politician leading the European
Commission leading the Europe European
Union so Germany's influence in the
European Union will be emphasized once
again at the same time there's a
question about what will happen here in
Berlin because one Minister in this
government will leave the government and
successor will have to be appointed and
with in German domestic politics all of
that least a whole lot of questions a
whole lot of insecurity in a sense so
within Germany I think in German
domestic politics this also contributes
to a feeling of a sense of instability
and questions hanging over the
government of Angela Merkel here in
Germany and thank you very much DW
political correspondent hunt pond